In a small, sleepy Oregon town, Jacob Pierce
was turning 10 years old.
His friends and family had gathered for a
birthday party in their local park.
It had all the makings of a perfect day for
a young boy entering the double digits for
the first time.
There was a hired magician attempting to make
balloon animals as children loudly mocked
him.
There was cake, ice cream, and an ice cream
cake for those who couldn’t make up their
mind about which they’d rather have.
There were pizzas, pepperoni and cheese, and
bowl after bowl of chips.
Jacob was having the best day ever.
As he blew out the candles on his birthday
cake, he quietly wished for something amazing
to happen.
It was already a good day, but it was also
a little bit mundane.
A fan of science fiction and fantasy, Jacob
had always quietly hoped that turning 10 would
usher in an era of magic and mystery.
Perhaps he would encounter aliens for the
first time.
Maybe he would solve a grand mystery or learn
about a civilization of tiny people living
in his backyard.
Or maybe, just maybe, he would wake up to
find he had acquired magical powers.
Suddenly, he would cease to be an ordinary
young boy who had to worry about math homework
and playground bullies.
He would instead become something special,
someone who could change the world around
him and finally make a difference, just like
the heroes of all of his favorite books.
So, as his mother set the cake down in front
of him and everyone sang “Happy Birthday”
with loud, off-key enthusiasm, Jacob closed
his eyes and wished.
Little did he know that his wish was about
to come true.
At least, it sort of was.
After cake, it was time for every kid’s
favorite part of their birthday party: the
presents.
A stack of colorfully wrapped packages sat
on the picnic table, just waiting to be unwrapped.
Jacob bounced excitedly, waiting for his mother
to give the all-clear.
She gathered all the kids, and Jacob’s nineteen-year-old
brother Nathan, and instructed them to sit
down and watch Jacob open his gifts.
He tore the paper from board games, action
figures, and an ill-advised stuffed animal
or two, when suddenly Nathan produced a package
he hadn’t seen before.
It was a small lumpy item, wrapped in green
paper.
He handed it to Jacob, who, thrilled to be
receiving a special present from his beloved
older brother, immediately opened it.
There, was a toy dart gun, already loaded
with a large foam dart.
Overcome with excitement, Jacob jumped up
from his seat and asked if he could play with
it now.
His mother said it was fine, and Jacob and
his friends immediately jumped into action.
They ran across the park, as Jacob aimed the
dart gun and decided which target to fire
it at.
As he squeezed the trigger, aiming for his
best friend Trevor, Nathan called out to him.
“Don’t shoot it at him!”
He yelled, with sudden urgency.
Startled, Jacob moved at the last minute,
and the dart fired at a nearby stone wall
instead of its original nine-year-old target.
As soon as the dart hit the wall, it transformed
into a wobbly stack of large stones.
The stones tumbled down, landing on several
people standing nearby.
A man who had been leaning on the wall fell
to the ground, where his leg was crushed under
a falling stone.
The magician, who was packing up his supplies,
took a rock to the head and was immediately
knocked unconscious.
The park broke into pandemonium, people running
and screaming, trying to figure out how a
previously solid wall had turned into falling
rocks.
Nathan scooped up Jacob, the gun, and the
dart and pulled him away from the chaos.
Someone called the police, where an embedded
SCP Foundation operative was alerted to the
situation unfolding.
Before Jacob and his family could vacate the
park, two SCP operatives were already arriving
on the scene.
After speaking with several eyewitnesses,
they identified the source of the anomalous
activity as the toy gun, and seized it for
further investigation.
All witnesses, including Jacob and his mother,
were given amnestics in order to erase their
memory of the toy gun and the incident in
the park.
Nathan Pierce, who was considered a person
of interest for his initial possession of
the gun could not be found.
He fled detection and Foundation custody,
further indicating his knowledge of the gun’s
anomalous properties, and possibly indicating
he was responsible for its creation.
His online activity linked him to an organization
satirically called Gamers Against Weed, a
Group of Interest that had previously been
linked to other anomalies seized by the Foundation.
His younger brother Jacob had, without any
knowledge, received a birthday gift that would
become designated SCP-3108.
SCP-3108 is a modified Nerf brand dart gun
that, when paired with its foam dart ammunition
- designated SCP-3108-1 - demonstrates anomalous
transformative properties.
When it fires other Nerf darts, it behaves
like an ordinary toy, and the same goes for
the dart when fired from any other Nerf gun.
The only notable difference between SCP-3108
and any other ordinary toy dart gun is the
writing on the side, which reads “OP PLS
NERF” in red ink.
When SCP-3108 is fired at an object, it will
immediately be transformed or altered in a
way that turns it into a worse version of
itself.
This can range anywhere from small changes
to complete transformation on a molecular
scale.
The law of conservation of mass does not apply
to these changes, and the gun’s effects
appear to defy the laws of physics.
The transformed objects are not themselves
anomalous in any way, and the changes they
undergo appear to be influenced, not by objective
reality, but by the opinion of whoever wields
the gun.
Whatever the person firing SCP-3108 thinks
would make the target worse, is what comes
to pass.
An external examination of SCP-3108 revealed
that it is made of a steel outer shell, with
decorative bronze inlays.
It can be physically damaged but resists any
attempts to take it apart.
Security Officer Silva attempted to take it
apart with his hands during a round of tests,
but before he could break open the shell he
found his hands had transformed into a pair
of rubber gloves.
They hung, limp and useless from his wrists
as he flopped them around yelling for assistance.
Officer Silva was promptly placed on leave,
and no more attempts to disassemble SCP-3108
have been made since.
Aside from this one instance, SCP-3108 does
not have an effect on objects that are not
directly hit by its dart.
A variety of tests were performed, headed
by Dr. Johnson and Dr. Dietz, in order to
further examine the anomalous properties of
SCP-3108.
First, a traditional dart board made of sisal
fibers was set up on the wall of the lab.
When hit with SCP-3108-1, the dart board changed
to a cork board of the same shape and size,
filled with several small holes and bearing
a noticeable beer stain.
A piece of eight by eleven printer paper was
transformed into a square of single-ply toilet
paper.
A sturdy coffee mug from the on-site cafeteria
changed into a small tea cup made of the same
kind of ceramic.
A dollar changed into a fake one hundred dollar
bill from the board game Monopoly.
It was determined that the gun’s effects
are determined by the personal preference
of the person firing it when it was fired
at a can of Coke.
The can immediately turned into a can of Pepsi,
much to the dismay of Security Officer Mike
who was observing the experiment and who preferred
Pepsi.
He took the gun next, and fired it at the
can, which promptly turned back into Coke.
On another day of trials, a VHS tape of the
1971 film Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
was transformed into a DVD copy of the 2005
remake of the same film, prompting the research
team to wonder: Does the gun have a sense
of humor?
It seemed to.
Next, the research team began conducting trials
on living organisms.
A rat was transformed into an ant, which Dr.
Dietz found confusing.
A female Golden Retriever was turned into
a female American Shorthair cat, unusually
large at a weight of 15.4 kilograms, and displaying
behavior more consistent with that of a dog.
After rats and dogs, the team decided to move
forward into human trials.
A 28-year-old male was hit with the gun, and
promptly turned into a living specimen of
Homo Neanderthalensis.
Right before the research team’s eyes, he
regressed into a real, live Neanderthal.
After this trial, the team decided to see
how dangerous the gun could be if pushed to
the limits.
Security Officer Gardiner was handed SCP-3108
and ordered to fire the gun repeatedly, reloading
each time, until told to stop.
A 24-year-old man was instructed to stand
in firing range and remain still.
First, he transformed into a prehistoric man.
Then, an unidentified species of gibbon,
and next, a three-toed sloth.
On nine occasions of the gun being fired,
the subject did not change species but rather
took on physical signs of injury or disease.
After 46 shots, testing was finally stopped
after the subject was reduced to a small variety
of earthworm.
After attempting to track him down unsuccessfully
for months, Nathan Pierce was finally located
by Foundation personnel and apprehended at
an Internet café in Los Angeles, California.
He was taken into custody and brought to Site-64
for questioning about the creation of SCP-3108.
Dr. Dietz conducted the interview, and asked
why Nathan created the gun.
Nathan referred to it as “the Nerfing gun,”
and explained that he thought it would be
funny.
It didn’t have any particularly grand purpose
or intention, it was just something he had
come up with and thought would be entertaining.
He experimented with it for a while, got bored
of it, and then gave it to his brother as
a gift.
His only regret was not giving his brother
a proper warning on how to use it before doing
so.
Dr. Dietz applied a little pressure, insisting
that the anomaly was dangerous and could turn
“people into invertebrates.”
This stopped the interview cold, as Nathan
became visibly distressed.
He insisted that it was never intended to
be used on people, but for low-level mischief.
He concluded the interview by saying, “Why
would you turn a joke into a torture device?”
and demanded that Dr. Dietz leave his cell
and stop speaking to him.
Nathan Pierce was later released from custody,
and the containment procedures for SCP-3108
were updated with this new information in
mind.
SCP-3108 is contained in a standard anomalous
object containment vault in Site-64 and is
not allowed to be removed from said vault
except for use in experiments.
Proposed testing must be approved by Dr. Johnson
and Dr. Dietz before it can be conducted.
The gun may not be stored while loaded, and
the foam dart is stored in a separate containment
vault.
During any and all testing, SCP-3108 is only
to be handled by Site-64 security staff.
Only one officer may hold and fire the object
at a time, while a secondary officer observes
and watches for potential accidents or any
unapproved use of the item.
Researchers and D-class personnel are not
permitted to fire the gun, due to concerns
about safety and security.
It may not be used, under any circumstances,
in cross-testing with other SCP objects.
It is also forbidden from use in any testing
on humanoids, as this is now considered an
ethics violation.
How would you use The Nerfing Gun if ever
it fell into your hands, and what do you think
would happen?
Let us know down in the comments, or we’ll
shoot, and make your comments terrible.
Now go check out “Irresistible Pick-up Artist
SCP-3512 - The More You Know” and “Top
8 SCP Objects You Actually Want” for more
dark and often hilarious anomalies!